[Music]
just who in the hell do you think you
are
hey everybody is Charlie so there's a
whole bunch more Guardians to stuff
dropping James Gunn did this big QA
where he dropped all kinds of teasers
about the future of the guardians
franchise infinity war characters that
he cut out of the movie that I think I
know about so I'm gonna play this video
then I'll explain all the really big
stuff there's a new round of the Spider
Man giveaway I'm giving away those crazy
articulated action figures all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video so what I
did is I cut this down to the really
important stuff so I'll play this then
I'll explain about the character that he
cut out the third Guardians film in
Avengers infinity war stuff I don't know
if it's considered a spoiler if I say
something that's in the trailer but of
course the trailer features a song the
chain by Fleetwood Mac which is one of
my favorite songs of all time off of one
of my favorite albums of all time and
and it's an important part of guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 we also get a first
glimpse at Aisha played by the wonderful
Elizabeth the Becky who you might know
from the night manager for instance
she's a fantastic actress it was a very
interesting thing with Elizabeth she
came in and auditioned for Aisha and she
was so incredibly perfect that I only
auditioned one other person who was also
amazing I won't say who that is but I
only auditioned to people for Aisha
because Elizabeth came in and it was
like she was born to play this role it's
very much how I felt about dave bautista
in the role of Drax or how I felt about
Palm Clemente F in the role of mantis
it's like these people were born to play
those roles and it's it's nothing is
more exciting than finding those types
of of making those types of casting
choices and finding those actors out
there so anyway what are you guys saying
I'm turning on my sink again my worry is
that there will be too many Guardians to
get into a really good story with them
all okay so here's what I promise you my
promise to you the fans is that every
guardian will be
you know receiving what's more personal
attention than in the last film every
Guardian has their own unique story
their own unique character art they each
learn something maybe good maybe bad as
they travel on this journey this is a
story that is truly about all of the
guardians of the galaxy if there's one
thing we found from you know our test
screenings is that people love the
interweaving stories of all the
Guardians and the way they work together
and the first story was mostly the story
of Chris Pratt
I was playing Peter quill up the story
of Peter quill star-lord the second
movie is a story of all of the guardians
together it really does they each get
their own piece of the pie and I think
each of them are able to shine and and
it's been a marvelous experience to put
it all together in that way and some of
you know I had a much longer time to
write the screenplay for guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 than I did for
guardians of the galaxy vol 1 I was a
little rushed when I had to write the
first one so I'm really proud of the
movie I'm happy with the way it turned
out but I think that the second film is
a much more intricately plotted film
with a lot more exciting things in it
and just more unique in many ways
how did I decide on the new character
additions mantas Aisha well how did I
decide I mean I just really liked the
character of mantis and she fit in as
I've told people before it's no secret I
originally added two guardians as I was
saying I originally added two characters
to the guardians of galaxy vol 2 script
my initial treatment had two new
characters two new guardians I mean that
new characters there's plenty of new
characters Ayesha there's ego there's
taser face but I just I felt like after
I went through the treatment I felt like
there were too many characters frankly
and I do think that if there's anything
that so many movies have been suffering
from it's just too many characters even
in the comic books when I read comic
books today there's often too many
characters not each character doesn't
get their own story and so that's why
again I promise you each character is
given specific special attention about
who they
I would not have included them if they
didn't fit in in a very specific and
special way that goes all the way to
characters like crackling yondu's first
mate and taser face and you know these
other characters but yeah so mantis is
just somebody who I really liked a lot
there was another character they used to
be in the script who I took out who
hopefully you know will be in a future
Marvel movie you know you guys are
asking me about characters I could could
they ever show up Starhawk and people
like this and you know that's that's
that's that's that's always possible
somebody says in the infinity stone
there is no infinity stone and guardians
of the galaxy volume 2 it is a separate
story which is about the characters
within guardians it's about you know
Aisha and who she is and it's about
Peter Quill's relationship with his
father and and that's really what the
movie is about it is not about a Power
Stone and it's not about forwarding the
larger story of the Marvel Universe it
really is its own thing its own separate
fable any big Easter eggs plan for
volume - yes I have plenty of Easter
eggs and volume - as many as are in vail
um-- one probably I think so we have a
lot of Easter eggs in the movie and so I
hope you guys enjoy that watching it
it's you know I know a lot of you are
people who watch guardians of the galaxy
not one not two not ten but 50 60 times
and so giving you these guys these
Easter eggs is a lot of fun for me
um whether they're Easter eggs having to
do with you know the Marvel Universe or
you know other movies or anything can I
drop any hints about any more songs on
the volume 2 soundtrack well I mean you
can check out I mean a lot of people
know that there's a chance that Jay and
the Americans come a little bit closer
is in the movie because it is a song
that was played with a scene that we
showed both that the Brazil comic-con
and at San Diego comic-con this year so
please direct vol 3 well we will have to
see any chance we'll get a beta 3 Billy
ster egg I don't know who knows love
Drax more Drax love all sorts of Drax
love coming in here in the comments is
there another Marvel movie you would do
besides guardians of the galaxy I don't
know who
knows I mean I really love the cosmic
side of the universe I really I love
Marvel superheroes but i-i've made
guardians if you consider guardians a
superhero film I've now made four
superhero films but what interests me
more about guardians the galaxy isn't
that the superhero aspect what interests
me is the space opera aspect it's more
of a science fiction space opera film to
me and so that's what that's what is
really interesting to me right now and
that's the kind of movie I want to make
more so than a superhero movies so
so are there superheroes I love yes I've
talked about those superheroes I've
loved I love moon night I love the
Thunderbolts I love hit monkey not
exactly superheroes oh there's a lot of
Marvel I love Squirrel Girl
there's a lot of superheroes I really
love I love Shazam I love Batman I mean
these are these are all characters that
are great but but I'm not sure you know
what I want to do right now I love
making space operas more than that
though I've committed the past three
years of my life to making guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 as special and is
beautiful and is wonderful and it's
truthful as I possibly can and it's it's
at the end of a marathon for me am I
gonna have any involvement with infinity
war yes I'm an executive producer on
infinity war I've been working hard with
the Russo brothers with the Marvel guys
with Kevin Feige
to make sure that any of the characters
I'm involved with that are in that movie
are well taken care of and are as funny
as they should be and is honest and
truthful as they should be so I've been
dealing with them all the time I've been
talking to the actors on set every
single day as we as we go through
production and and it's been a it's been
a great experience so far how much focus
will Aisha get in vol 2 she gets a lot
of focus she's a very very important
character and she's a pretty bad villain
pretty bad I mean you know listen
nobody's 100% bad except for maybe maybe
Ronan was sort of under hood now even he
wasn't even hundred percent bad he had
his reasons for doing what he did so the
big thing the character that he cut out
of guardians of the galaxy to I think
that's Cosmo I think originally Cosmo
was going to be on the team but mantis
was the other new weird awesome
character he said there were just too
many things going on so maybe he'll make
it into a future film that's probably
cosmo you guys can let me know in the
comments though who do you think that
secret character that he cut out was now
keep in mind that they're probably a
space-based character it's not an
earth-based avenger and it's not a human
he's always said that Peter quill is the
only human on the guardians of the
galaxy team he wanted him to feel like a
unique person in outer space
so whoever the character he cut out is
it's some big deep cut and I just feel
like that all points to Cosmo because he
was such an awesome Easter egg from the
first movie in a really cool character
who also travels with the Guardians in
the comics the other big infinity war
thing he confirmed he's a producer on
the film working closely with the Russos
mostly with his characters the guardians
in the things that they're doing during
infinity war so there'll be a lot of his
unique qualities that you see in
guardians the really amazing visual look
the music that you will see during
infinity war I feel like the music is
the biggest thing - that's one of the
big things that differentiates guardians
from the other Marvel films they all
look great but James Gunn is just like a
step above in terms of his creative
vision but that actually reminds me so
he said no infinity gems no power stone
because that's still with the Nova Corps
the Guardians movie doesn't have
anything to do with pushing Marvel's
phase three story forward so that's you
know Thanos Infinity Gauntlet so that's
all relegated to Thor Ragnarok the other
really fun teaser is that he sounds more
and more like he's going to do a third
Guardians film which I feel like we all
felt was inevitable but early on before
they'd released the first trailer when
they had just finished filming he's like
I don't know guys but whatever's
happened since then it just sounds like
it's reenergized him like he's so happy
with the way the film has turned out
that he is totally down to do more with
these characters but we talked about the
rocket Groot spin-off film that's been
talked about but it might actually end
up being the basis for the third
guardians film so in the way the
guardians - doesn't necessarily have
anything to do with the Marvel phase 3
plotline the Thanos storyline the third
guardians rocket Groot movie might also
have the same relationship with phase 4
because it probably wouldn't come to
Marvel phase 4 just because the Doctor
Strange movies did amazing but
derrickson said that Marvel's so busy
they have so many films on their
schedule that dr. strange too isn't
going to come anytime soon but any of
that could change let me know in the
comments what do you think about the
idea of a rocket and Groot movie the
other guardians would be in it but it'd
be mostly their story as opposed to
Peter Quill's story so what's gonna
happen next is as they drop some new
Logan footage there's the Legion TV show
that's premiering this week and we may
have a synopsis for x-men supernova that
secret x-men film so I'll do a video for
that next then there was this really
cool Justice League preview they
released during the Superbowl I'll do a
breakdown for that later tonight so
another day of three videos there's just
so much comic book stuff happening
giveaway though p.m. gaming you win one
of the spider-man action figures please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details
it's a pre-order so they haven't started
selling them yet but they're gonna be
rolling them out really soon before the
spider-man movie comes out so there was
a new round that started in this video
all announced the winner the next time I
post a Marvel video there's gonna be a
whole bunch of stuff happening this week
so I'll try to post the videos as fast
as possible thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys in the next
video click here to rewatch that
Guardians trailer and click here for
stranger things season 2 trailer